[Music]
okay take a look at that palm tree right
over there that's not a California palm
tree
it's a Florida palm tree and I'm
currently in a city that had more than
30 movie studios made hundreds of films
[Music]
[Applause]
the city was locked in a fight with
Hollywood and if it won it could have
changed our culture but this gutted old
movie studio is just about all that's
left of it today
and the fact that this city lost says
something about early movies and how
hard it is for cities to embrace change
but if things had gone just a little
differently Jacksonville Florida might
have been the world's movie capital
[Music]
this is a typical movie studio around
1910 notice of the ceiling it's glass
covered by thin paper physical film
strips at the time needed so much light
that these studios were like greenhouses
and pricey artificial lights were just
starting to get good in the 1910s most
early American silent movies were made
in New York and this lighting
requirement created some problems it was
just one of the reasons movie studios
felt the call of Jacksonville New York's
light didn't compare to the Rays of the
Sun in warmer climates and this was
especially important with primitive film
cold weather also hurt cameras and
cameraman claimed to cause static that
produced cracks and scratches on the
film location was limited as well New
York could play a city but producers
wanted to be near beaches and jungles
Jacksonville and Los Angeles both did
that but Jacksonville was a relatively
short 26 hour train ride from New York
so it became a winter hub
[Music]
the vim headquarters in New York wanted
a presence in Jacksonville so they set
up an outpost and the famous Tannhauser
film company did the same massive new
studios were built this is the former
home of Eagle Studios a Jacksonville
native studio in 1916 where they shot
movies like this one a bathtub elopement
featuring goofy silent film comedian
Marcel Perez this is the production
office this is the safe where they
stored flammable film
and this is the on lot generator
so why is it empty today okay this is
almost dead imagine this happening in
your city right now I met Monroe and
Davis in Jacksonville where a mob of
more than a thousand extras almost
completely destroyed a saloon in the
movie the Clarion like totally destroyed
it okay it looked like that guy
this happened more than once
here's a crowd chasing a baby carriage
down this street in downtown
Jacksonville it held a very large baby
by the mid-nineteen tens Jacksonville
residents were starting to get sick of
movies over running their town
Jacksonville had extended a genuine
welcome to film like vim comedy and
eagle film the mayor was a film booster
who thought film would bring a new era
to Jacksonville he had the support of
every production company in Jacksonville
and the city was set to be a hub he was
up for election in nineteen seventeen a
year after that big riot during the
shooting of declaring businessman were
behind the mayor and he asked the people
of Jacksonville to vote for him and
support the motion picture film
companies he brought in he lost it was a
vote against corruption but also against
the movies running wild through
Jacksonville during this time Hollywood
had grown a lot despite being further
away from New York mismanagement of
companies in Jacksonville World War one
and in influenza outbreak didn't help
the Florida City there was a lot of bad
luck after the 1917 election a lot of
studios closed up shop in Florida the
city had in effect voted against a
future in movies in the meantime hit
movies like those made by legendary
director DW Griffith had made Hollywood
a home for film Hollywood was ready to
be a movie town Jacksonville couldn't
make the jump
Jacksonville shows us an alternate
universe for movies one were different
comedy teams became legendary where the
duo of Laurel and Hardy was plump and
run instead and there are other reasons
to beyond movie stars that sign up top
should say Norman laboratories after
Eagle Studios closed a producer named
Richard Norman bought it while Hollywood
made movies featuring actors in
blackface
Norman's Studios made films like the
flying ace starring heroic black
characters played by black actors he was
one of a few film studios that focused
on black audiences and black characters
and it sat outside the Hollywood system
it was in the mainstream if things had
gone a little differently in
Jacksonville our culture could have been
shaped by an entirely different set of
stories but instead all we have her a
few restored films and some buildings
that are waiting for the same
[Music]
alright that's it for this episode in
our series about big changes to movies
that came from outside Hollywood a lot
of places have actually started to
surpass Hollywood there's Nollywood
there's Bollywood there's Jiali wood
these are all real Google them so I want
to know if you think Hollywood will
endure let me know in the comments I
also want to give a shout out to all
most hollywood by blair miller all those
library scenes where i'm looking up
stuff on microfiche basically looking up
footnotes in this book and finding them
in the original newspaper so if you want
to nerd out a lot more on the history of
jacksonville florida get into the
specifics this is the book for you
[Music]